[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP on se retrouve comme chaque semaine
autour d'un plat d'un dessert et d'un
invité et cette semaine nous recevons
Priska t bonjour bonjour Merci d'avoir
accepter notre invitation et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour priscatvau
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire d'État
chargé de la jeunesse et du service
national universel d'abord porte-parole
du parti vous devenez député en 2022
vous vous engagez en politique pour
Emmanuel Macron et son projet
d'émancipation qui raisonne en vous pur
produit de l'école républicaine vous
avez fait vos études en ZEP à stetin en
scène saintniis avant d'intégrer le
prestigieux lycée h Franklin dans le 16e
arrondissement puis une école de
commerce et vous vous lancez dans
l'entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui vous êtes
au gouvernement alors tout cela aurait
pu vous monter à la tête mais non vous
avez choisi de nous parler de vos
origines et ça commence sous les
cocotiers n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre à l'Î
Maurice oui en effet avec une spécialité
au menu mauricienne avec une recette
insolite un plat insolite un bol
renversé on verra ça tout à l'heure
c'est assez drôle et en dessert un
crumble aux pommes dans le dessous des
plats l'inflation alimentaire plonge les
jeunes dans une grande précarité nous
avons suivi Mélissa dans une collecte
alimentaire dans les pieds dans le plat
l'obésité explose dans le monde entier
la France n'est pas épargnée les jeunes
sont le plus touchés à cause de la
malbouffe reportage à suivre allez on
passe à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence alors priscv avant même de
connaître votre recette j'avais dit à
Brigitte avec un peu de bol on aura
droit à une dose d'exotisme avec un plat
mauricien je ne croyais pas si bien dire
car en fait on a disons une double dose
de bol on a le bol cette chance donc de
goûter à la cuisine de vos racines et le
plat lui-même puisque oui il s'appelle
je n'invente rien la chance de vous
avoir avec nous exactement le bol
renversé c'est drôle je ne savais même
pas que ça existait pour être précis
c'est un plat populaire de l'île mauris
mais ses origines sont plutôt chinoises
cette recette Brigit c'est un œuf cuit
au plat une coup de légumes de viande de
crevettes sauté au bois qui enfin une
couche de riz blanc alors on met tout ça
dans un bol d'abord l'œuf ensuite la
viande ensuite le riz et puis c'est un
peu la tarte
tatin du riz et là maintenant et bien on
a renversé le bol et il faut lever
délicatement devant le
convive attention et hop non c'est bien
et donc on a du coup en le renversant et
bien l'œuf qui devient du coup qui trône
sur ce dô de viande en l'occurrence ça
c'est du poulet et des crevettes et puis
de riz blanc alors merci priscat EV pour
cette recette insolite et je me dis
vraiment qu'on a vraiment du bol de la
partager avec vous j'espère que c'est
réciproque tout à fait alors c'est comme
ça que ça se présente effectivement dans
les restaurants ex c'est exactement
comme ça que Ben dans les souvenirs de
mon enfance ça se présente alors je
rajouterai quand même qu'il y a des
légumes c'est important et pourquoi je
j'insiste sur ça parce qu'en fait on a
un repas complet oui réellement complet
et c'est un repas moi qui me fait c'est
un peu pardon du la comparaison mais
c'est un peu ma madeleine de proue à moi
parce que c'est les souvenirs où on se
retrouvait dans la cuisine avec mon père
ma mère qui cuisinait beaucoup beaucoup
ensemble et donc vous voyez bien que le
bol renversé il faut tout cuisiner à
part et donc après c'était génial pour
moi en tant qu'enfant de faire
l'assemblage de machin et puis après de
voir qu'il avait le mieux assembler
quand on le renversait dans l'assiette
il est mieux renversé chez vous que chez
mien que le mien mais en fait
effectivement il y a des petits maïs des
petites pousses de maïs il y a du bambou
il y a des carotte du CH des oignons
j'ai l'impression aussi exactement ouis
et alors dites-nous une chose parce que
l'œuf en fait vous vous le mettez dans
dans quel sens parce que en fait comment
vous faites pour faire cuire l'œuf et le
mettre après au fond du bol faut juste
le faire glisser dans le bol ououis et à
l'envers ou à à l'envers il faut que le
jaune soit au fond du
bol ah oui mais il faut pas que le le
soit crev très attention c'est une belle
technique alors pour la petite histoire
parce que on trouve pas ça dans toutes
les brasseries de Paris hein le bol
renvé je l'ai trouvé au restaurant
Mascarine dans le 11e et c'est Roland
jundou le chef qui m'a préparé ça ce
matin rien pour nous CIT la carte donc
si vous aimez si vous aimez cette
recette et bien allez 202 boulevard
Voltaire et vous pouvez déguster un bol
renversé je crois que d'ailleurs que
vous êtes une familière de ce restaurant
ah bah oui j'adore et il y a plein plein
de recettes à découvrir à partager poup
et surtout moi ce que je conseille c'est
ceux qui seules et ceux qui veulent y
aller prenez différents plats et puis
partagez en fait c'est ce qu'on aime
beaucoup faire moi je me quand je suis
arrivé au secréta quand je suis arrivé
au secrétariat d'État c'est ce que j'ai
dit à mes mes équipes on va se faire un
déjeuner puis on dit on va dans quelle
brasserie jeis vous allez venir puis
prenez chacun une assiette un plat
différent on va partager puis on va
comme ça vous allez pouvoir tout goûter
et c'est comme ça aussi que on fait
aussi beauou Maurice c'est on partage on
n'est pas simplement arrivé sur son
assiette on cuisine beaucoup l'Î Maurice
vous disiez c'est vos parents vraiment
qui aimaient ça ah oui ça fait partie de
la culture aussi de passer du temps ben
ça se retrouve avec la culture française
en fait ce plaisir de se retrouver en
convivialité autour d'un plat ensemble
chacun découvrant les saveurs des autres
et c'est vrai que le bol renversé à a
une origine asiatique mais il se
retrouve et est devenu un plat populaire
à l'île Maurice et donc c'est pour ça
que ça permet la rencontre en fait des
saveurs des histoire et quel chose qu'on
aussi en France donz leu ver parce que
moi j'ai hte de goûter on va goûter et
vous nous dites si ça correspond au goût
de votre enfance alors ça va être
difficile évidemment d'avoir la même
recette et et les mêmes souvenirs que
que ceux de vos parents mais est-ce
qu'on retrouve un peu ce ce goût là
délicieux le goût d' Maurice oui ouais
ça y est on a on a voyagé là regardez
Brigitte l'œf il est bien cuit là Roland
a bien fait le boulot regardez l'œuf il
est pas dur le jaune va couler sur les
la la viande le poulet est crevette hein
et puis t les petits légumes qui sont là
il sont vraiment et ça vous le
préparez vous aussi pour vos enfants
aujourd'hui c'est un plat que vous
faites régulièrement à la maison c'est
quelque chose qui est plaisant à faire
parce qu'on le fait ensemble avec les
enfants avec et après c'est celui qui va
dire ah bah toi tu as tu as cassé ton
œuf toi tu l' pas bien donc c'est génial
c'est génial et puis VO l'importance de
mettre tous les différents aliments et
alors est-ce que c'est toujours les
mêmes aliments est-ce qu'on on retrouve
parce qu' il y en a avec du poulet avec
des crevettes on mélange tout ça oui
vous pouvez aussi faire sans poul et
crevettes on peut faire que des légumes
on peut faire végétarien on peut en fait
il y a plusieurs comment variantes un la
logique reste la même du bol renversé
mais après on on compose son bol comme
on veut on peut le faire parfaitement
végétarien par ex ce que m'a dit Roland
lui il fait ce plat là mais en fait on
peut demain vous pouvez faire vraiment
sur mesure votre bol rvers c'est que des
légumes euh des légumes français là il
rajoute parce que c'est vraiment une une
une recette chinoise à l'origine là dans
la petite sauce il y a de la sauce
d'huîre de la sauce de soja de l'huile
de sésame ce qui lui confère quand même
ce goût un peu asiatique mais après le
bol renversé peut êre très FR a cette
influence asiatique qu'on retrouve dans
ce plat mauricien parce que l'île
Maurice est fait de sa diversité h avec
des influence européenne asiatique
afrien française et anglaise que
asiatique tout à l'heure sur les ben de
tout en fait sur des choses à savoir sur
la cuisine mauricienne exactement au
travers effectivement des des
différentes étapes de la colonisation
qui ont été très européenne mais
effectivement il y a aussi beaucoup de
cultures chinoise asiatique en général
indienne bien évidemment et en fait
toutes ces nuances toute cette diversité
ne s'efface pas elle se permet de se de
de venir mettre en richesse plein de
choses au sein du pays parce qu'il y a
le cadre qui qui reste quand même le
cadre national et à l'intérieur de ça la
diversité s'épanouie librement et
Jean-Pierre disait que c'était un plat
populaire c'est c'est un peu est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un peu
les restes du frigo ou pas du tout ah
non c'est pas les restes du frigo c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un plat
populaire parce qu'en fait on peut le
faire assez rapidement on trouve
facilement les aliments que les aliments
restent quand même accessibles parce
qu'on peut faire évoluer la recette
aussi mais c'est quelque chose qui se
fait assez simplement oui mais c'est pas
les reste du frigo non mais j'allais
rebondir quand même sur ce que disait
Brigitte avec des restes du frigo on
peut faire aussi un B rversé typiquement
vous faites vous faites quelque chose
avec du riz la veille VO un peu avec des
légumes et et vous faites un bol
renversé VO jeanre trois choses à savoir
du coup sur la cuisine ma très vite fait
parce que on en a un peu parlé c'est
normal puisqu'on mange un bol renversé
c'est vrai que la cuisine mauricienne
c'est un savour mélange de tradition
culinaire on l'a dit créole chinoise
indienne africaine française sur l'île
Maurice par exemple je crois que vous y
aviez été vous commencez par un
croissant au petit déj le matin un carry
épicé ou un rougail de poisson ou de
saucisses au déjeuner et un Brian ou des
mines frites chinoises au donc vraiment
on a un vrai panel de cuisine autre
trésor de la cuisine c'est c'est la
street food très varié abondante
impossible de visiter cette île sans
goûter au dol pourri m'at-on dit j'ai lu
que c'était un peu l'équivalent
mauricien de notre jambon beur c'est une
crêpe salé à base de poids cassé que
l'on Treme dans une sauce c'est
incontournable à Maurice c'est vraiou
pasou c'est la base voilà c'est ind on
le mange comme ça dans la ça se mange
dans dans au bazar enfin au marché on
dit le bazar nous on va au marché on
part pas du marché avoir mangé son dalle
pourri bien évidemment mais dans votre
journée vous avez oublié le thé le thé
au lait le thé au lait oui c'est vrai le
TH on boit beaucoup de thé à Maurice et
la dernière spécialité de cette île
c'est naturellement les poissons et les
fruits de mer puisque c'est une île
poulpe appelé là-bas ouride qu'on peut
manger en caris parfumer aux épices les
camarons Camaron écrevis d'eau douce et
le marlin bleu sans arrête un délicieux
poisson associé à une salade de cœur de
palmier on a fait le tour de l'Î morce
on a fait le tour de l'île morurice il
mon juste quand même quelque chose c'est
quand même la tradition bre de l'Î
Maurice la phenniix ah la phenniix et ça
c'est aussi un incontournable et là je
pense qu'on a fait le tour il a les
brassé sur place oui donc la phenniix
ben voilà la Phénix alors sauf que là on
a du vin blanc parce que vous nous avez
vous avez souhaité qu'on accompagne ce
plat avec un un vin d'Alsace un vin
blanc sec qui est un wristling donc le
wristling c'est le plus ancien sépage
d'Alsace et un des plus nobles avec le
givers straminaire avec avec quoi
d'autre le pinoc gris le Musca donc ce
ce vin blanc c'est une aosée évidemment
oui et vous l'avez choisi parce que
parce que vous êtes né à Strasbourg
parce que je suis alsacienne exactement
je suis d'origine mauricienne par mes
parents je suis né en Alsace et
aujourd'hui je suis en île-de-fance mais
parce que c'est important effectivement
et c'est mêlé tradition plaisir du
terroir avec aussi un très gros plaisir
de la table en Alsace qu'on retrouve et
et donc c'est vrai que c'est un vin que
j'apprécie énormément Wrestling ou
givers framinire sylvanir enfin il y a
beaucoup de on a le choix on a choix en
Alsace il y a quand même une très grande
tradition et effectivement un vignoble
très ancien avec un héritage extrêmement
fort et puissant et une route des vins
magnifique si on veut aller se promener
du côté de ex exactement et d'ailleurs
on arrive bientôt sur les les fêtes de
fin d'année c'est assez connu pour c'est
très festif au moment de Noël voilà dès
tout le mois de décembre est festif faut
y aller faut vraiment y aller alors donc
vous vous avez ces souvenirs là en
Alsace mais vous y avez vécu ou j'ai en
fait j'ai pas vécu en Alsace j'ai passé
mes deux premières années de vie très
vite mes parents sont arrivés en
île-de-fance mais c'est vrai que mes
parents eux s' sont mariés et ils ont
vécu beaucoup plus longtemps que 2 ans
et donc c'est vrai que et bien on a on
retourne souvent enfin en tout cas quand
mon père est encore vivant on retournait
souvent à Strasbourg j'ai encore une
tante qui est à Strasbourg donc on est
très attaché à Strasbourg et ça se
retrouve dans l'assiette aussi
c'estàdire que y a il y avait des
chourout à la maison il y avait un
certain nombre de de spécialités de
là-bas bah alors la chourot on la
faisait pas à la maison mais mais oui on
aime bien à chouroû mais quand on va
justement à Strasbourg parce que ça fait
aussi partie des rituels c'est bien
aussi d'avoir de temps en temps des
petits rituels et puis de se dire que
c'est un moment un peu à part et puis
c'est exclusif donc oui quand on va à
Strasbourg il y a la Forêt Noire enfin
il y a plein de choses alors vous aimez
vous aimz parler de la cuisine ça on l'a
déjà bien compris vous avez donc double
racine quand on est au fourne où est-ce
que vous cuisinez vous aimez cuisiner on
va on va on va être honnête 2 secondes
ou j'aime bien cuisiner mais depuis
quelques temps j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps ça je le comprends tout à fa et
par contre j'ai un mari qui adore ça oui
et qui arrive encore à prendre le temps
oui oui il cuisine très très bien mais
vous quand vous êtes au fourneau quand
vous étiez au fourneau vous étiez plutôt
Maurice ou Strasbourg ah plutôt Maurice
plutôt Maurice plutôt Maurice parce que
parce qu'en fait c'est ce qui me reste
de mon enfance j'ai vu beaucoup mes
parents moi je vous le dis on passait
nos weekends dans la cuisine et c'était
vraiment le plaisir le moment ça veut
dire qu'enfant c'était plutôt de la
cuisine mauricienne à la maison que non
il y avait de tout il y avait de tout il
y avait de tout mais c'est vrai que
c'est les moments où voilà moi j'étais
dans la cuisine je me souviens et puis
je piquais toujours etve C
arrête il en restera plus pour après
donc oui c'est vraiment on cuisinait de
tout et encore aujourd'hui c'est pareil
euh après je peux aussi essayer de temps
en temps des recettes on aime bien
essayer et voir comment ça ça prend puis
après on se trompe un peu puis on
recommence non non j'aime beaucoup et
pour les ingrédients c'est pas trop
compliqué parce que là il y a parfois
des ingrédients un peu plus compliqués
on le trouve pas au supermarché du coin
ah si on trouve de tout alors je vais
pas dire peut-être le nom du supermarché
ou mais dans des grands supermarchés moi
je vais dans les hper tout ce tout ce
qui est bon pour faire de la la cuisine
chinoise
tout ah bon ben vraiment vous donnerez
l'adresse qui pas d'urou beaucoup
d'épices dans la cuisine mauricienne
c'est c'est quel genre d'épices qu'on
retrouve parce que on en trouve aussi
beaucoup dans la cuisine africaine mais
c'est c'est pas forcément les mêmes
c'est pas les mêmes enfin si les bases
sont quand même les mêmes mais pas
utilisé de la même façon et pas mélangé
de la même façon c'est vrai que nous on
a beaucoup déjà en base c'est alors
au-delà des épices c'est l'ail et le
gingembre qu'on met quand même
partout ça c'est la base de ça il y en a
dans dans tous les plats dès qu'on fait
un sauter un rougail là dans les légumes
à mon avis il y en a base de gingembre
et et d'ail et ensuite toutes sortes
d'épices qu'on peut trouver en fait et
c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui et j'aime
bien rappeler que l'épice n'est pas
forcément pimenté le piment fait partie
mais tout n'est pas pimenté parce que
souvent on me dire mais ça va être épicé
oui épicé c'est parfumer pimenter c'est
fort alors là on a un piment al alors
moi j'ai j'ai juste mis Brigit juste ça
la pointe de la fourchette et alors vous
êtes SAÉ au plafond j'ai failli tousser
et et mir oui alors on va peut-être pas
vous faire goûter ah moi j'adore
alors d'une j'adore et je vais vous
faire une petite confidence parce qu'on
est en confidence aussi un de mes
ministres de tutelle qui s'appelle
Gabriel Atal adore aussi manger pimenté
pour Monsieur at d'accord alors vous lui
rapporterez on va vous faire un petit
doggy bag il va être content il en a
pour 10 ans là parce que euh ça va non
non il aime très pimenté mais alors le
piment se mange avec le bol renversé on
en met par-dessus ou le piment se mange
avec tout avec tout ah oui on en met
dans tous les plats partout oui après
c'est si on aime mais c'est vrai que
donc c'est épicé et pimenté c'est très
relevé oui on choisit mais après le
piment n'est jamais imposé dans le plat
toujours à côté parce que bah les
enfants typiquement les enfants
typiquement leur donnent pas ça c'est
pas possible ils peuvent pas c'est enfin
c'est quand même donc on met toujours à
côté et chacun se sert mais vraiment
c'est c'est le principe de la table à
l'Î Maurice c'est que on met les plats
et après on et chacun se sert et mange
comm il veut au rythme qu'il veut avec
rythme qu'il veut ce qu'il veut et puis
parce que on peut avoir autour de la
table des gens qui sont végétariens
d'autres pas et cetera donc en fait
comme ça tout le monde est à l'aise tout
le monde est à l'aise il y a pas de plat
que chacun peut se servir et la
tolérance par rapport au piment c'est
une petite question puisque vous êtes
des îles et que est-ce que finalement
plus on en mange tôt plus on s'habitue
ou il y a des palais qui sont faits pour
ça ou pas parce que en France ça
personne n'en veut de ce genre de de
piment c'est trop fort alors pour être
très transparente jusqu'à mes 30 ans je
ne mangeais pas du tout pimenté mais pas
du et votre palais a évolué alors et mon
palais a évolué quand je suis tombée
enceinte parce que j'ai un peu perdu le
goût j'avais pas assez de goût je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé et donc je
cherchais à avoir un peu plus de saveur
et c'est là que j'ai com commené à
manger pimenté et vraiment très pimenté
et à l' Maurice tout le monde en mange
enfin je veux dire c'est c'est habituel
quoi enfin les les palais sontabitue en
fait peut-êtreou bah après on en mange
pas quand on est petit enfin de toute
façon de manière naturelle et évidente
on donne pas du piment à des enfants
mais après c'est vrai que bah ça se fait
plus ou moins naturellement mais tout le
monde ne mange pas de piment mais c'est
vrai qu'il y en a sur la table et est-ce
qu'au ministère vous avez donné quelques
consignes ou quelques recettes pour
manger un peu mauricien non je me perd
mettrait pas déjà on a une très bonne
table avec vraiment une vrai un plaisir
d'être à table et donc c'est c'est très
agréable mais c'est vrai que quand j'ai
envie bah de manger mauricien
ou un peu différent de ce qui est
proposé bah de toute façon très simple
c'est aussi l'occasion de dire aux
équipes ben on va juste aussi s'aérer un
peu parce que c'est vrai que quand on
est secrétaire d'État ministre on nous
voit souvent nous dehors mais nos
équipes elle reste souvent au bureau en
fait et donc c'est aussi des occasions
aussi pour nous ben de sortir un peu et
puis de découvrir d'autres d' d'autres
choses en allant directement mettre en
avant nos restaurateurs oui en me
plongeant dans cette cuisine mauricienne
tout à l'heure je crois que vous l'avez
dit Brigite il y a aussi des influences
françaises on a beaucoup parlé des
influences chinoises indiennes mais
alors j'ai lu qu'on mangeait par exemple
de la DAE du chevreuil et du sanglier
moi j'imaginaer l'île Maurice avec trois
cocotiers et des plages blanches on
mange du chevreuil sur l'île Maurice ENF
il y a des chasses des domaines de
chasse par il y a des ah oui il y a des
domaines de chasse à l' Maurice il y a
des temps de chasse qui s'ouvrent et
cetera bien évidemment et c'est c'est
des moments aussi un peu endu parce que
ça fait partie de ces moments un peu un
peu un peu voilà où on se retrouve tous
mais après encore une fois c'est
personne n'est obligé personne n'est
contraint mais c'est juste le respect
des uns et des autres c'était pour
comprendre cette complexité cette
diversité de cette cuisine ah non mais
quand je vous dis que si on devait
chercher une devvise pour l'île Maurice
c'est la diversité c'est la diversité
toutes les nuances sont présentes et je
le redis elles peuvent exister elles ne
sont pas antagonistes parce parce qu'en
fait elles se rappelle qu'elles sont
dans un cadre qui est le cadre de lîle
avec effectivement une langue commune
qui est le créole mais nous parlons
aussi anglais français à la maison et ça
ne choque personne on peut être à table
parler français puis d'un seul coup
changer parce qu'on va raconter une
blague et on va la raconter en créole
parce que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
drôle en créole et puis d'un seul coup
parler anglais parce qu'il y aura une
news qu'on aura lu en anglais et que on
va pas dénaturer puis on va la on va la
la décrire en anglais et donc toute
cette diversité aussi bien dans euh les
les visages de l'Î Maurice que la
gastronomie que les langues parlées que
le paysages de l'île Maurice aussi
témoignent de cette capacité à pas vivre
ensemble mais faire ensemble alors il y
a toute cette diversité effectivement ça
veut dire que vous vous mangez de tout
ou est-ce qu'il y a vraiment il y a des
des aliments que vous n'aimez pas je
mange de tout mangez de tout en tout cas
je goûte toujours à tout et c'est en
tout cas t dit par exemple pas une chose
que vous détestez ben en fait si il y
avait une chose que je détestais
vraiment quand quand j'étais petite
alors le piment mais parce que j'avais
pas j'avais pas été habitué et euh les
les tomates cuites ah ah mais souvent
les enfants n'apprécient pas tellement
les tomates chaudes VO impossible et
puis en fait à chaque fois moi je je
reteste et maintenant bah voilà ça passe
et maintenant vous aimez ça j'aime ça
bon je vais pas me faire des tomates
cuites comme ça mais je veux dire je
pense qu'il faut toujours retester le
palais évolue tout au long de la vie et
donc de temps en temps il faut retester
c'est pas grave si on aime pas bah on a
goûté h voilà c'est le message que vous
adressez aussi à vos enfants et à la
jeunesse
toujours moi je leur dis toujours goûter
et c'est vrai que j'ai la chance d'avoir
deux enfants qui du coup acceptent ils
goûtent tout mais je les oblige jamais
mais ils goûtent tout après sils aiment
pas ils aiment pas mais ils goûtent et
alors on voit que les les les tendances
évoluent aussi les goûts évoluent est-ce
que vous vous avez modifi votre
alimentation au long des tout au long
des années est-ce que vous mangez par
exemple autant de viande qu'avant est-ce
que votre alimentation est est
différente je mange beaucoup moins de
viande qu'avant h c'est vrai que euh je
manger alors que ce soit la viande
blanche ou rouge au moins une fois par
jour sur un des repas et et c'est vrai
que enfants ados et jeune adulte en fait
et et et depuis ouais depuis à peu près
plus de 10 ans non je mange pas de la
viande tous les jours donc j'ai aussi
fait évoluer ma façon de manger mais au
regard aussi bah du des sociétés dans
lesquelles on évolue et des informations
que nous avons et de cette capacité
aussi à dire que bah il y a des choses
qui sont pas forcément mauvais
mais qui doivent être un peu modéré dans
notre alimentation et que l'alimentation
doit se regarder plus que sur une
journée peut-être sur une échelle un
échelle de temps plus long comme une
semaine par exemple donc c'est pour des
questions de santé écologique aussi ou
tout tout tout mais en fait et mais là
je le dis aussi j'ai beaucoup évolué
avec mes enfants h c'est mes enfants qui
m'ont ramené aussi beaucoup de ces
sujets à la maison et j'apprends
énormément avec eux et je trouve ça très
agréable de dire que on apprend aussi
avec nos enfants bien évidemment la la
norme veut que ce soit dans l'autre
chose dans l'autre sens mais on apprend
aussi beaucoup avec nos enfants je vous
donne un exemple moi j'avais
effectivement j'ai grandi avec des
bouteilles d'eau en plastique à la
maison oui mais c'est une aberration et
donc c'est avec aussi que j'ai évolué
bah maintenant j'ai ma carafe qu'on
remplit à l'eau du robinet puis c'est
comme ça pareil dans la salle de bain je
n'ai plus de bouteille en plastique j'ai
un shampoing solide voilà et donc j'ai
évolué comme ça aussi beaucoup avec mes
enfants alors on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollable c'est le
quiz
alors Prisc on l'a compris vous êtes fan
de cette cuisine d'origine mauricienne
et encore une fois merci de nous avoir
fait partager ce ce bol renversé
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
ingrédients queon va voir sur l'écran
entrent dans la recette d'une autre
recette et d'une autre spécialité
mauricienne le fameux Calia de poulet
ahah oui alors est-ce qu'il y a du
yaourt nature dans cette recette oui
bravo est-ce qu'il y a des œufs
durs dans le
Calia
euh j'aurais dit non il y a des œuf durs
ah ou on peut mettre est-ce qu'il y a de
l'anice étoilé on appelle ça la badiane
oui oui la Badian est-ce qu'il y a de
lanette non voilà ah pas mal pas mal
bien même bien très bien euh alors l'Î
Maurice est aussi l'un des rares pays à
avoir sur son sol une vanille de qualité
sariez-vous nous dire quel est le pays
qui ne produit pas cette gousse divine a
le Sri Lanka B l'Ouganda C la Grèce et d
le Mexique dans quel pays on ne trouve
pas de vanille la Grèce la Grèce
exactement ça veut dire qu'on en trouve
au Sri Lanka en Ouganda et au Mexique ce
qui est quand mêmeou voilà alors le Sri
Lanka peut-être c'est pas loin de mais
ce qui m'a étonné c'est l'Ouganda mais
effectivement il y a de la vanille dans
en Ouganda et au Mexique et à l'île
Maurice et vous vous mangez beaucoup de
de vanille vous aimez beaucoup ça moi je
mets dans le sucre je la je la fonds en
deux et je la mets dans le sucre ça
parfume le sucre c'est génial alors
c'est souvent autour de la T que ce nous
les deal politiques se fait la petite et
la grande Histoire et c'est la breève de
comptoir alors Prisc TV on vous a
demandé de nous raconter une petite
histoire une petite anecdote politique
autour d'un repas est-ce qu'il y a une
une une histoire qui vous est revenue à
l'esprit une histoire qui m'est revenue
à l'esprit effectivement c'était avec
mon grand mon mon mon fils Paul donc il
y a 9 ans aujourd'hui et on était à
table C j'étais encore parlementaire et
donc j'étais rentrée pour juste pendant
la pause parlementaire pour dîner avec
eux et en fait j'étais préoccupée enfin
j'étais en en fait j'étais avec eux mais
j'étais pas là et j'étais encore en
train de penser à ce qui se passait dans
l'hémicycle ce qui peut arriver souvent
enfin je le reconnais et et cette
fois-ci j'étais assise en face de lui
mon petit étant sur le côté et là il me
dit mais à quoi tu penses fallait pas
revenir et donc ah ben il a raison donc
et puis donc je me dis ben je le raconte
non mais je lui raconte je dis bah voilà
il s'est passé ça il s'est passé ça mais
tu te rends compes il c'est c'est dur ce
sujet alors je je lui dis pas avec des
mots d'enfants avec comme je l'ai vécu
dans la journée puis il peut tout à fait
comprendre sans dramatiser euh c'était
un sujet qui avait eu lieu sur dans la
journée sur la binationalité dans
l'hémicycle porté par une certaine
partie de l'hémicycle et donc je lui
explique et je lui dis bah tu vois moi
ça me pose problème parce qu'ilimagine
on fait comment maman moi je fais
comment maman elle fait comment et il me
regarde il me fait ah bah je vois pas
pourquoi il me dit je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça te prends la tête prends des
forces et
retournees-y ça vous a donné du courage
je me suis dit oui et après il me bah tu
t'es engagé en politique c'est pour que
ça il me dit enfin il m'a pas dit que tu
engagé en politique tu t'es engagé avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est pour que ça change
donc et puis vraiment c'est en gros
respecte ce temps de repas qu'on est en
train de vivre ensemble alors c'est pas
c'est pas super drôle c'est pas mais je
trouve que c'est très symbolique aussi
c'est peut-être aussi apprendre nous de
temps en temps à aussi déconnecter à se
dire on coupe et à profiter du moment HM
et le repas c'est difficile en politique
mais dans la vie de tous les jours pas
qu'en politique
h ou on est absorbé par son travail et
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à écouter les
autres à
donc cette anecdote elle revient en
permanence dans votre tête quand vous
êtes pris en flagrant des lit mais il
faut qu'on soit enfin peu importe qu'on
peut mettre dans son assiette aussi mais
il faut aussi qu'on soit capable de de
temps en temps ben prendre le temps
d'apprécier le moment présent et du coup
est-ce que ça vous avez changé est-ce
que du coup maintenant quand vous êtes à
table en famille vous vous dites bon ça
je le laisse en dehors maintenant c'est
le temps du repas et et c'est un temps
familial que je je leur consacre oui
alors quand
quand je peux le faire oui je le fais
vraiment je le fais vraiment et donc en
fait on parle de tout et de rien et
c'est c'est génial c'est génial et ça
permet aussi de respirer enfin ça fait
une respiration quoi h et il s'intéresse
quand même à la politique vos enfants à
ce que vous faites ah bah ils ont pas eu
le choix je crois j'ai commencé à
m'engager avec avec effectivement le
président de la République à l'époque
candidat le petit avait le grand avait 2
ans et demi et le petit venait tout
juste de naître et donc je me souviens
encore à l'époque c'était avec Laurent
saint-mar
où on mettait les tractes sous la
poussette parce qu'en plus du coup
c'était pratique il dormait il y a un
petit espace pour mettre pour faire
dormir un enfant on promena la poussette
et du coup c'était génial donc ils ont
toujours été là ils ont je les ai
toujours emmené quand c'était alors ils
ont pas tracté non ils tractent pas
quand même mais quand il y avait des
réunions publiques ou quoi s'il vouleit
venir je les faisais venir ils étaient
dans un coin et sans réellement
participer il VI il voit ce que c'est en
fait il voit très clairement ce que
c'est et ça leur donne envie de faire de
la politique ou au contraire ça ça
verront conent sur apprendre à l'école
et puis après ils auront tout le temps
de venir voir alors on va parler d'un
sujet qui est éminemment politique c'est
l'inflation alimentaire qui plonge les
jeunes dans une grande précarité alors
peut-on conserver une alimentation
équilibrée c'est le dessous des
plats après un pic de 16 % en mars
l'inflation alimentaire devrait refluer
à 7 % en décembre une hausse des prix
qui oblige beaucoup d'étudiants à se
rendre dans des collectes alimentaires
c'est le cas de Mélissa Clément perouau
et Marion de Vauchel l'ont suivi à
l'université de viltaneuse en scène
Saint-Denis ils sont les visages de la
précarité étudiante ce jour-là la
collecte alimentaire sur le campus a
enregistré 150 bénéficiaires dans la
queue de nombreux étrangers comme
Mélissa étudiante algérienne j'ai pas de
bourse du coup je dois travailler pour
subvenir à mes besoins mon salaire c'est
entre 400 et 500 € et je paye mon loyer
364 € du coup c'est peu pour pour
acheter autre chose normalement j'ai un
TD mais voilà j'ai je suis pas parti
juste pour prendre quoi manger en fait
du coup oui ça influence sur mes études
pour éviter de rater trop de cours à
cause des collectes Mélissa s'est
organisé avec ses copines c'est pour
trois personnes oui pour moi et deux
autres ils ont tous inscrit
oui normalement inscr après des fois
c'est ell qui vient en fait on
s'organise ça dépend des
jours mlissa fait le plein de produits
d'hygiène de conserves et de fruits et
légumesour de quoi se préparer un repas
équilibréour sal de fruit ça fait du
bien ouais les légumes faire des gratins
au légumes des soupes aussi c'est
important parce que là il commence à
faire
froid en fain pour les fruits et légumes
c'est même pas une semaine pour autre
chose ça peut tenir ouais c'est déjà ça
sinon il y a d'autres distributions à
côté on va chaque
mercredi des fois samedi dans d'autres
associations faut le rajouter dans son
plan la collecte ce jourl est organisée
par l'Union étudiante un syndicat de
gauche qui dénonce une envolée de la
précarité dans les campus les prix ont
tellement augmenté au niveau de
l'alimentaire même pour les dres de base
que il y a beaucoup de difficultés des
étudiants à se nourir qu'est-ce qui pèse
sur le budget d'un étudiant c'est
surtout les produits d'hygiène les
produits les plus chers mais ça va être
également l'habillement ça va être
l'alimentation et la principale chose
c'est quand même le logement à l'issue
de cette collecte 750 kg de denré ont
été
distribué our brisc EV vous avez entendu
Mélissa elle est obligée de rater les
cours pour pouvoir se nourrir pour
pouvoir aller chercher de la nourriture
pour elle pour ses amis pour pouvoir
manger est-ce que c'est normal
aujourd'hui en France vous avez déjà la
réponse dans votre question en réalité
l'enjeu que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est
bien évidemment en tant que politique en
tant que responsable politique de ne pas
nier les réalités les difficultés que
nos jeunes nos moins jeunes rencontrent
effectivement au quotidien du fait de
l'inflation et d'autres enjeux encore
nous avons répondu bien évidemment avec
différents dispositifs sur l'inflation
générale je vais pas les rappeler ici
parce que ce n'est pas l'objet mais nous
devons continuer à le faire et nous
avons par exemple travaillé là on
parlait beaucoup des étudiants et le
représentant syndical le disait très
juste titre il a fallu aussi faire
évoluer certains dispositifs qui
existaient qui n'étaient plus vraiment
en adéquation avec le contexte
économique et financier tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui et c'est pas moi qui
le dis c'est pas nous le gouvernement
qui l'avons réfléchi à l'intérieur de
nos bureaux mais c'est bien à l'issue
d'une d'un échange qui avait eu lieu
entre le Président de la République
lui-même et des jeunes qui lui avait dit
bah en fait nous ne pouvons pas accéder
au système de bourse donc ça veut dire
étendre le système de bourse que vous
avez fait pour et c'est pour ça qu'il a
ét qu'il a été il a été on l' on l'a
réformé on l'a fait évoluer avec ma
collègue justement Sylvie rotaillot qui
a pu le mettre en place dès cette
rentrée là c'est concrètement c'est quoi
c'est 35000 jeunes étudiants qui ne
pouvaient pas être boursiers jusque-l
qui avec effectivement une situation
identique aujourd'hui sont devenus
boursiers c'est cas mlissa alors elle
elle est pas boursière justement non
mais c'est pour ça déjà il faut déjà
pouvoir raeler ça parce que je pense que
c'est il y a aussi un problème 35000
35000 qui sont devenus boursiers alors
pou beaucoup comme ça mais à l'échelle
du la population étudiante c'est pas
énorme non plus et c'est 140000 qui
étaient déjà boursiers et qui ont eu une
revalorisation sans avoir de changement
de situation tous les étudiants ne sont
pas boursiers et c'est heureux on doit
pouvoir cibler ses aides sur celles et
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin c'est le
principe maintenant ce qu'on do aussi
pouir regarder c'est dans sa globalité
c'est qu'effectivement il y a de
nombreuses associations qui sont aussi
sur le terrain pour voir effectivement
des profils comme Mélissa donc là aussi
nous les aidons parce que je suis
secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse au SNU
et à la vie associattiveyz beaucoup au
cours de vos déplacements des jeunes qui
vous disent c'est difficile c'est
difficile de manger c'est difficile de
se loger et donc de travailler mais bien
évidemment depuis que je suis arrivé au
secrétariat d'État à la Jeunesse c'estd
maintenant il y a 3 mois à peu près ma
première mon premier point a été de
surtout pas m'installer dans le bureau
et de très vite aller en région sur le
terrain pour pouvoir parler aux jeunes
partout et donc l'enjeu c'était pas
qu'il m'écoute mais qu'on puisse
réellement échanger puorter des
solutions voilà et donc sans caméra sans
médias je préfère le dire c'est pas que
je ne veux pas vous avoir à côté de moi
mais parce que les échanges sont pas les
mêmes et parce qu'on parle de de sujets
qui touche aussi beaucoup à la
sensibilité des uns et des autres et
c'est pas forcément facile et donc oui
ça nous permet aussi d'adapter les
politiques publiques que nous menons
parce queon fait des grandes réformes
elles sont là concrète hein quand je
vous parle de 35000 boursiers de plus ou
de 140000 qui ont eu leur leur bourse
augmenté mais il faut aussi qu'on puisse
voir peut-être dans certains détails où
il y a encore des choses à ajuster alors
ce qu'elle dit là Mélissa c'est que le
logement prend une très grande partie de
de ce qu'elle a en fait de ce de
l'argent qu'elle peut avoir ce qui
empiète évidemment sur l'alimentation
est-ce que sur le logement étudiant on
peut faire un effort particulier alors
il y a déjà eu des choses qui ont été
faites notamment aussi par ma collègue
Sylvie rotaillot je préfère l' nommé
pour rendre hommage aussi à son travail
sur notamment le cru avec bien
évidemment le sujet des repains 1 € ou
3,30 € alors le ropa en euros c'est le
tarif social ou le les Bour c'est si on
est boursier ou si on est effectivement
en situation de fragilité mais c'est
aussi la le gel des loyers au niveau du
cru le sujet du logement doit se voir de
façon plus générale et là je référerai
aussi à mon autre collègue Patrice
vegrit qui justement travaille sur ces
enjeux et il faut être très clair ça ne
pourra pas se faire d'un Big Bang ça
sera pas mesure phare c'est quelque
chose assez long qu'on doit pouvoir
engager mais sur lesquels on doit
pouvoir aussi apporter des réponses
immédiates et donc elles vont être
diverses et variées et c'est en ça que
vous voyez aujourd'hui je vous parle de
la jeunesse je vous parle d'autres
collègues parce que mon enjeu aussi
c'est d'être bien évidemment ce
ministère du lien des jeunes entre eux
des jeunes avec la société des jeunes
avec le monde associatif mais moi aussi
du lien que je fais avec mes autres
collègues je ne peux pas parler de la
jeunesse moi toute seule je le fais
forcément avec mes deux ministres de
tutelle Gabriel Atal et Sébastien
Lecornu mais mais aussi avec l'entièreté
du gouvernement c'est REP pas à 1 € dont
on parlait le président avait annoncé
deux repas à 1 € est-ce que ça ça va
perdurer est-ce que aujourd'hui on peut
midi et soir quand on est boursier
manger pour pour 1 € et puis est-ce que
c'est repa à 1 €
finalement il pourrait concerner tous
les étudiants on se souvient que dans
l'hémicyc de l'Assemblée nationale la
gauche l'avait proposé la majorité
l'avait refusé est-ce que c'est pas une
erreur finalement alors voilà le tout le
sujet et merci de poser la question déjà
rappelons que la création du repas en
euro je suis désolée j'aime pas faire ça
mais on va falloir quand même aussi
remettre de temps en temps les pendules
à l'heure euh c'est le président de la
République qui l'a mis en place au
lendemain de la crise pendant la crise
covid nous l'avons créé je n'ai entendu
personne venir expliquer qu'il fallait
le créer jusque-l euh et nous l'avons
pérenisé parce que c'est devait être un
dispositif dans un dans un dans une
durée de temps limitée et nous l'avons
pérenisé sur par exemple et j'étais
encore député le dernier projet de loi
de finances euh de l'année dernière que
toutes les oppositions et notamment
cette gauche a refusé de voter quand il
refuse de voter le budget de financeces
quand il refuse de de voter les textes
financiers il refuse très clairement de
mettre en place ce genre de dispositif
qu' après ils viennent de façon
démagogique nous reproposer sans avoir
les crédit derrière ensuite sur le sujet
du 1 € pour
tous la question qui se pose c'est c'est
bien de le décréter comme ça mais est-ce
que c'est possible est-ce que nous avons
les capacités en terme de CROUS en terme
de bâtiment en terme d'infrastructure
pour le faire première chose ensuite
est-ce que notre enjeu ce n'est pas
surtout de cibler les aides pour celles
et ceux qui en ont le plus besoin parce
que je vais le dire de façon très
claire les fonds de l'État les deniers
publics c'est l'argent des Français et
ce n'est pas illimité et donc cette
proposition de loi qui avait été portée
à l'époque par Louis Boyard je me
souviens j'étais dans l'hémicycle à
toutes ces questionsl il n'y avait pas
de réponse son seul enjeu Ctait il sont
parfois en rupture avec leur famille en
fait c'est pas parce que les parents
gagnent
assez d'argent pour que le le jeune ne
soit pas boursier que forcément il il
puisse demander beaucoup d'argent à ses
parents enfin ils ont aussi envie d'être
autonome et ce et vous avez refusé enfin
au gouvernement en tout cas qu'il ait
cette allocation pour les jeunes ou un
revenu universel le Président on a
encore parlé récemment mais de quoi on
parle en fait on a en fait c'estes deux
ces deux visions de société
effectivement qui sont
différentes nous notre enjeu depuis 2017
c'est d'être dans l'émancipation et dans
la capacité pour chaque jeune d'être
maître de son destin ça veut pas dire
qu'on va le laisser se débrouiller tout
seul on va l'accompagner on va mettre un
certain nombre de dispositifs en place
pour que justement il n'est pas à être à
ce sentir et moi c'est pas moi qui le
dis c'est les jeunes que je rencontre et
j'en ai vu notamment en Creuse ou à
l'île de la Réunion ou à Bordeaux ou à
Lyon ils le disent tous ils ne veulent
pas être administrés ils veulent être
responsabilisés ils veulent être
responsabilisés et donc nous devons leur
donner les capacités de le faire
aujourd'hui donc au travers de l'école
au travers des enseignements supérieurs
effectivement avec le système de bourse
qu'on a fait évoluer avec aussi la L
lutte contre la précarité menstruelle il
faut en parler mais c'est un coup pour
les jeunes filles tous les mois dont on
a beaucoup on a très peu parlé jusqu'à
présent ça va passer dans le budget de
la Sécurité
sociale et il est temps pendant
longtemps c un tabou parce que ça ça ne
concernait que nous les les jeunes
filles et donc tout ça on doit pouvoir
le regarder de façon assez claire mais
sans démagogie sans démagogie et le le
le sujet de l'aide universelle de l'aide
universelle la question
c'est les jeunes veulent surtout pouvoir
travailler trouver le bon emploi
l'emploi qui paye bien et c'est ça qui
va être l'enjeu aujourd'hui alors juste
parce que vous parliez de Louis Boyard
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un petit échange
assez drôle sur Twitter Louis Boyard a
tweeté hier je crois le ministre la
ministre de la Jeunesse m'a invité à
venir visiter un SNU avec elle ça fait
la transition avec le SNU je luis poser
une condition d'accord à condition
qu'elle vienne visiter une distribution
alimentaire avec moi elle ne m'a pas
répondu alors je lui demande ici on
organise ça quand c'est pas moi qui vous
le dis hein c'est Louis board oui oui je
rere alors alors Louis Boyer est quand
même
assez génial pas dire autre chose c'est
qu'en fait c'est l'homme de la capsule
et du challenge c'est-à-dire qu'en
permanence il est là pour faire du buzz
pour faire parler de lui mais que de lui
ça marche ça fait pas aver les choses
pardon mais c'est pas c'est pas sa
responsabilité non mais c'est important
mais ça fait pas bouger les choses
est-ce qu'on parle pas de ces sujets là
du coup non mais c'est là c'est d'une
hypocrisie sans nom parce qu'en plus je
lui ai répondu à cet échange c'est qu'on
était en audition justement en train de
parler des budgets alloués à la jeunesse
Louis Boyard est venu pour faire sa
capsule en me parlant de respect il m'a
fait une grande leçon une grande
tyrannie sur le respect une grande
litanie sur le respect je lui dit écoute
c'est gentil de me parler de respect
mais en fait regarde aussi comment tu te
comportes et charité bien ordonnée
commence par soi-même et donc je lui dis
tu parles beaucoup du SNU viens avec moi
et on va y aller ensemble et on va
regarder ce que c'est mais alors est-ce
que vous allez aller dans une collecte
alimentire donc il m il m'a mis une
condition je lu dit de toute façon toute
proposition il m'a pas de toute manière
il m'a pas répondu pour le SNU mais il
m'a mis une condition en me disant viens
échanger venez échanger pardon avec avec
des jeunes de toute façon tant qu'on
propose dès qu'on proposera de venir
échanger avec des jeunes je viendrai
donc vous allez donc vous lui dites oui
non mais vous vous plaisantez je lui ai
répondu en audition oui mais monsieur
Boyard qui avait fait sa capsule n'avait
aucune intention d'écouter la réponse il
le B sur le BZ vous êtes vous êtes sûr
de ça je lui ai répondu après j'ai
capsulé et j'ai capsulé et tout c'est je
l'ai fait la même chose c'est dommage je
voulais pas le faire je l'ai fait le
lendemain parce que j'ai vu qu'en fait
il continuait je pensais qu'il allait
rectifier en disant ben elle m'a répondu
et cetera pas du tout et c'est c'était
très désobligeant pour ses collègues qui
étaient là et qui ne savaient pas quoi
dire parce que quand je lui ai répondu
je dis bah je lui réponds mais il n'est
plus là on parlait de la précarité pas
seulement alimentaire mais est-ce que ça
vous la vous la voyez vous la percevez
chez ces jeunes du SNU que vous essayez
de de faire vivre ensemble mais les frag
les fragilités elles existent qu'elles
soient d'ordre alimentaire d'ordre
familial d'autre psychologique moral et
puis aussi sur plein d'autres sujets qui
les traversent
typiquement par exemple ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes les répones
qu'on pourra apporter ça je c'est c'est
c'est pas l'objet l'objet c'est aussi de
répondre à un enjeu aujourd'hui de
cohésion nationale vous savez je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de l'île Maurice
on a besoin aussi de savoir qu'on est
dans la même équipe et je le dis
d'autant plus qu'on est en année
olympique aujourd'hui enfin cette année
et bien rappelons-nous qu' qu'on est
dans la même équipe rappelons-nous qu'il
faut aussi provoquer des échanges des
rencontres avec des jeunes qu'on aurait
peut-être pas rencontré par ailleurs
c'est ça le SNU et c'est pas simplement
aller se rencontrer mais c'est se
rencont en faisant avec qui avec des
associations locales sur un tas de
sujets que les les jeunes nous adressent
eux même sur le harcèlement sur le lien
police population sur l'environnement et
la biodiversité et bien en fait c'est
apprendre à se rencontrer apprendre à se
connaître ça veut dire qu'il faut rendre
obligatoire ce SNU ou pas parce que on a
vu que vous aviez des des prises de
parole qui ont parfois pu être
contradictoire estce qu'il faut le
généraliser et le rendre
obligatoire elles sont absolument pas
contradictctoires c'est juste mais j'ai
bien fait d'avoir une deuxième
explication parce qu'en fait c'est vrai
que souvent on considère que Twitter est
l'alpha et l'oméga de la communication
Twitter c'est des capsules de 2 minutes
20 sur une interview de 30 minutes
effectivement on peut capsuler et et pas
se rendre compte de l'entièreté du
propos moi ce que je dis de façon très
claire c'est qu'avant de parler
d'obligation il faut faire l'explication
du SNU beaucoup de gens m'ont beaucoup
dit obligation ou pas obligations sont
comprendre ce qui était le SNU par
exemple je le dis j'étais à la cour
neuve il y a de cela de 3 semaines avec
des jeunes et la première des première
pas des questions c'est
d'interpellations a été moi j'ai pas
envie de faire le SNU je ne veux pas
faire le SNU je dis très bien mais
qu'est-ce que le SNU et là ça a fait
babobi bobu je je ne sais pas donc je
dis ben très bien ben on va en parler et
quand je lui explique alors il m'a dit
c'est 22 jours avec des militaires dans
un camp militaire je fais pas du tout
oui parce que vous dit c'est un service
militaire déguisé col c'est ni une colo
ni l'armée et celui qui me dit que
regarder le drapeau se lever et chanter
la Marseillaise c'est être militaire non
c'est être français je suis désolé et ça
aussi il faut peut-être rappeler aussi
les symboles de la République et les
remettre à leur juste place et donc
quand je commencé à lui expliquer je lu
dis voilà je te dis ce que c'est après
tu me dis si tu as vraiment pas envie
d'y aller il a pas répondu mais ça veut
dire qu'en 2024 pardon Jean-Pierre mais
en 2024 du coup ce sera pour toute une
classe d'âge entre 15 et 17 ans en
principe he alors déjà depuis 2019 quand
ça a été lancé par Gabriel Atal entre
2019 et maintenant il y a 90000 jeunes
qui l'ont fait c'est vrai que là on va
rentrer sur une phase d'accélération
puisque rien que sur l'année 2024 c'est
80000 jeunes qui vont le faire il y a un
dispositif SNU tel qu'on le connaît
c'est hors temps scolaire et maintenant
le SNU va rentrer aussi dans le cadre du
projet pédagogique annuel donc dans le
temps scolaire donc pour tous les
enfants et donc tous les donc ça c'est
toujours sur la base du volontariat mais
je vous le dis de façon très claire
aussi pour peut-être lever quelques
Totem et tabou sur le mois de juillet de
cette année 17000 jeunes sont partis en
séjour de cohésion SNU ça veut dire 127
cent ouvert en simultanée 17000 jeunes
il y en a 5000 qui ont pas pu y aller
parce qu'on avait pas assez de place
disponible ça aussi il faut s'en rendre
compte on a des jeunes qui veulent faire
le SNU donc nous notre enjeu c'est de
cette montée en puissance cette
montée de façon très forte en
généralisation je le dis mais il faut le
faire aussi en cadence au au regard de
toute la mécanique à à mettre en place
et donc oui l'année prochaine nous
allons continuer cette accélération de
la montée en puissance du SNU alors on
va parler d'un autre sujet qui concerne
la jeunesse et qui touche beaucoup
beaucoup nos jeunes c'est le surpoids
comment aborder le sujet quelle solution
existe-t-il des recettes miracles on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le plat
oui brigitte c'est un fléo qui connaît
une forte augmentation chez les jeunes
de 18 à 24 ans l'obésité dont souffre
Lucy 18 ans qui habite cuset près de
Vichy pour perdre ses kilos en trop elle
a parié sur une méthode innovante qui
mèle atelier de réflexion et nouvelles
habitudes alimentaire c'est un reportage
dans l'alliier de Dario borgognot et
André
Laffond sur cette photo Lucy pesait
presque 100 kg depuis elle en a perdu 20
même avec le soutien de son compagnon se
replonger dans ses souvenir reste une
épreuve on voit que je me j'essaie de me
trouver une robe qui a ma taille mais
que en fait ça me va pas du tout puisque
je me trouve vraiment immonde à cause de
son obésité elle subit les moqueries de
ses camarades durant toute la primaire
et au début du collège je me suis fait
harceler parce que j'étais pas dans
l'énorme j'étais beaucoup enveloppé je
faisais je faisais beaucoup de beaucoup
de kilos j'ai fait une phobie scolaire à
cause de ça j'ai arrêté de me nourrir
parce que du coup ça ça me détruisait en
fait le fait d'avoir des remarques tous
les jours au bout d'un moment on n plus
envie de manger en se disant bah je vais
me laisser mourir de faim et puis ça
marchera
peut-être pour s'en sortir Lucy suit
depuis 2 ans un programme gratuit à
domicile avec des professionnels de
santé basé notamment sur des jeux de
rôles je vousn
que là tout de suite Lucy est attention
elle est
anxieuse alors de quoi elle aurait
besoin à ce moment-là papa dit j'aurais
besoin d'être comprise oui ah
bien en discutant avec les parents les
enfants on va réfléchir à ce qu'on
pourrait
modifier dans les dans les dans le
quotidien pour prendre en charge un
petit peu ces questions d'obésité et de
surpoids mieux communiquer mais aussi
mieux se nourrir proxob apprend aux
adolescents en surpoids à rééquilibrer
leur repas et au niveau des quantité
féculant je réduis les féculant en ce
moment donc je décide de prendre qu'une
louche et j'augmente euh les légumes
puisque ça c'est à volonté c'est ce qui
permet de maigrir le plus une petite
révolution culinaire pour toute la
famille on mange mieux voilà et on mange
en plus petite quantité pu qu'on sait
maintenant quand est-ce qu'on a faim bon
je remplissais bien les assiettes et
puis h les cal maintenant bon c'est fin
terminé les sodat à table moins de
chocolat et surtout plus de fruits Lucy
suit les conseils de proxo pour ne plus
comme elle le dit manger ses émotions
résultat de meilleurs plats et un esprit
apaisé même sans compter physiquement
mais
même le regard envers elle-même elle
s'estime mieux pour moi c'est important
que ma fil se sente bien proxob a déjà
aidé plus de 300 familles en oververn
ronalp et espère à présent se
généraliser sur toute la France priscat
EV que pensez-vous de l'efficacité de ce
genre de programme plus malin que des
régimes pur et dur ou ou gadget mais
vous le voyez très justement avec cette
jeune fille qui elle sourire aux lèvres
qui en plus met des mots sur ce qu'elle
ressentait qui en parle librement et qui
n'a pas honte de dire ce qu'elle ressent
et je trouve ça extrêmement fort
extrêmement puissant et puis elle elle
elle fait vivre ça à sa famille ils le
vivent ensemble elle le vit pas toute
seule elle le partage et c'est des
moments en nouveau de convivialité
peut-être de de redécouverte de certains
liens familiauxx le but c'est qu'elle
perde des kilos quand même he c'est le
but qu'elle perde des kilos mais pas
qu'elle perde des kilos pour perdre des
kilos le but c'est qu'elle se sente bien
et je pense que c'est ça qui est
important elle le elle le disait dans le
reportage elle mangeait ses émotions et
bien l'enjeu c'est qu'elle puisse parler
de ses émotions et il n'y a rien de
mieux que de çafin elle peut perdre des
kilos et puis se sentir toujours tout
aussi mal c'est pas l'objet c'est une
préoccupation de votre ministère
peut-être en lien avec la santé tout à
fait et c'est c'est une préoccupation du
ministère c'est une préoccupation de
l'entièreté du gouvernement et c'est
surtout une difficulté que les jeunes
nous disent il y a un sujet
effectivement de surpoids d'obésité mais
il y a aussi un sujet de trouble
alimentaire qui s'est d'autant plus
amplifié après la crise covid et oui
avec anorexie
boulimie ai et ça il faut qu'on puisse
en parler et aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
soit aussi en capacité de d'entendre la
parole et de la provoquer de pas
simpleement dire salut comment tu vas
mais d'être en capacité d'entendre la
réponse et d'être en capacité d'entendre
une réponse qui serait négative ça peut
faire mal quand on est parent d'entendre
son enfant qui dit ça va pas ça peut
faire mal il faut se le dire franchement
mais il faut qu'on puisse aussi être
accompagné c'est pour ça que je dis
c'est aussi tout un c'est tout un un
envie rodement familial aussi qu'il faut
embarquer parce que c'est toute la
famille en fait qui est concernée on a
l'impression qu'on est resté à manger
cinq fruits et légumes et que c'est un
peu le mantra et que ça suffit faut pas
aller un peu au-delà et ESS bien sûr
qu'il faut aller au-delà bien sûr qu'il
faut aller a-delà il faut déjà lutter
contre la sédentarité ça c'est très
simple et bien et dès le début il faut
se créer des réflexes il faut qu'on
redevienne cette nation sportive je vais
reprendre les termes de ma collègue
amélio Costera de façon très simple
c'est 30 minutes de sport par jour à
l'école ça se fait moi je le vois je
suis pas Simp en place véritablement
j'ai deux enfants sa j'ai deux enfants
oui al j'ai entendu dire qu'il n'était
même pas en survêtement donc les 30 le
temp se changer et puis de de se
rechanger en fait donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire avec une chemise est-ce qu'
pece que minutes de de sport par jour
est-ce que c'est pas aussi se dépenser
aller
marcherer voilà donc il faut aussi
pouvoir dire ça on a pas besoin dans
donc c'est pas forcément de sport c'est
d'activité voilà parce que le sport
c'est un sens un peu c'est le sport per
et bien vous avez raison c'est de
l'activité physique vous avez tout à
fait raison de me reprendre sur ce terme
là on n'est pas obligé d'être dans une
salle de sport pas du tout et donc ça
nos jeunes prennent le réflexe parce que
du coup ils vont le garder le réflexe du
sport ça se garde de bouger de proposer
des choses et d'être dehors et puis
d'être aussi d'être en groupe en
cohésion bien aussi pour pour le mental
c'est bien pour tout c'est bien pour
tout et ensuite il y a aussi cette
capacité comme le disait Lucy dans votre
reportage de pouvoir aussi comprendre ce
qu'est une alimentation saine et
diversifiée et ça c'est bien de le dire
mais il faut aussi l'expliquer et bien
pareil là et bien il y a tous ces sujets
qui sont travaillés au sein de l'école
c'est le rôle de l'école d'apprendre ou
c'est plutôt le rôle des par ils le font
tout le monde vous savez moi j'aime pas
parler d'élèves j'aime bien parler de
jeunes ou d'enfant pourquoi parce que
vous allez comprendre tout de suite la
logique de la continuité
pédagogique la la la la pédagogie ne
s'arrête pas aux portes de l'école nous
sommes tous responsables en tant
qu'adultte tous ceux qui évoluons autour
de nos enfants qu'on soit parents
proches direct ou simplement dans nos
entourages proches les bien évidemment
le monde éducatif responsable nous avons
cette responsabilité
d'apprentissage d'autorité
d'apprentissage sur les jeunes et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pouvoir parler
d'enfants et de jeunes parce que tout au
long de la journée tout au long de sa
vie tout au long de sa semaine et bien
le jeûne va continuer à apprendre et
comme je vous le disais aussi tout à
l'heure on apprend aussi beaucoup d' il
faudrait pas des politiques plus
contraignantes parce que là vous parlez
de l'école qui va éduquer les élèves sur
la malbouffe mais les industriels qui
produisent des produits trop sucrés trop
gras quasiment addictif il faut pas un
peu de temps en temps mettre le haut là
euh faire des seuiles de sucre dans
certaines boissons dans certains
produits éviter des produits addictif
qui fait qu'on mange des barres
chocolaté comme ça euh 5q dans la
journée est-ce qu'il y a pas des mesures
à apprendre coercitive vers les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire et bien
là vous faites le lien directement avec
toute l'action qui est en train d'être
menée par ma collègue Olivia grégoir
justement sur ça surtout dans le pays de
la gastronomie encore une fois quand on
dit gastronomie comme vous me reprenez
sur le sport quand on dit gastronomie on
a l'impression tout de suite que ça va
être extrêmement cher avec des produits
extrêmement luxueux pas du tout la
richesse de la gastronomie française est
justement d'être une une gastronomie
accessible qui s'adapte aux saisons
Olivier agrégard c'est sur le fait
maison c'està-dire comme ça on évite les
produits industriels ou justement bien
c'est important c'est important aussi de
rappeler le fait maison et encore une
fois je suis pas en train d'opposer
l'industriel avec le tou fait maison il
faut qu'on puisse être en harmonie aussi
et décomplexer aussi les choses on peut
pouvoir de temps en temps se faire un
burger dans un fast food ou une pizza
c'est pas grave c'est pas on n pas une
mauvaise personne et puis aussi rappeler
que l'alimentation ne doit pas en
revanche être que ça ça peut être des
moments de plaisir mais le moment de
plaisir aussi ça peut être de cuisiner
en famille de se retrouver entre ami par
exemple là je vois le dessert qui est
arrivé moi ce dessert là oui regarde
depis tout à l'heure j'adore il est fait
maison che mais j'ai vu un chiffre
dingue à propos de justement des papiers
qui sont sortis après le travail
d'olivierre greégoire c'est moins de 10
% des restaurants en France font 100 %
du fait maison c'est dingue moins de 10
% mais c'est pour ça que je dis il faut
aussi pouvoir le faire mais le fait
maison c'est à la maison aussi et ça
c'est aussi important c'est des moments
au-delà de partager en plus de partager
ce moment à table c'est aussi partager
ce moment dans la cuisine à faire
ensemble alors je je vois que vous
regardez allez on y passe tout de suite
et c'est le péché
mignon avec un crumble aux pommes alors
pour la petite histoire Brigitte le
crumble a été créé au Royaume-Uni
pendant la deuxième guerre alors que s
vissé un rationnement des ingrédients
nécessaires pour faire des gâteaux le
beurre la farine le sucre donc le
crumble est une sorte de gâteau de crise
parce qu'en fait on mettait des fruits
qui étaient pas trop cher on arrivait à
les trouver dans le verger puis après
comme on avait pas beaucoup de beurre
pas beaucoup de farine pas beaucoup de
sucre mais on faisait un peu de voilà on
émettit un tout petit peu de pâte
au-dessus on faisait on pouvit pas faire
une vraie pâte à tarte donc on la
mettait par-dessus puis après on passait
ça au four c'est très bon c'est devenu
le crumble d'ailleurs crumble en anglais
ça veut dire amietté voilà c'est votre
dessert favori j'aime bien crble un peu
le bol rversé aussi ça moi j'aime bien
le crumble parce que c'est facile à
faire avec des produits qu'on trouve
assez rapidement qui sont pas très
onéreux et puis aussi parce que moi ça
me rappelle je je faisais ça beaucoup
quand j'étais étudiante parce que je
vivais en colocation et c'était le plat
qu'on pouvait faire en grand plat pour
tout le monde pour pas très cher et on
était très content parce qu'on le
partageait puis je me souviens on
mettait même P se le partager
directement dans manger directement dans
le plat et pas toujours aux pommes si
toujours au pommes ah toujours aux
pommes parce que il y a des variantes
maintenant on peut trouver dans avec
n'importe quel fruit ah oui je sais pu
il a des crumble même il y a du chocolat
dedans et cetera
crumbleouou moi je suis très ouais
classique je suis très alors le crumble
salé par exemple non vous avez jamais
essayé avec des avec des légumes oui si
si j'ai déjà j'ai déjà goûté mais c'est
pas ce qui moi je suis très classique
vous ah je su TR alors goûtez-le a plein
de fruit sur l'île sur l'île Maurice
vous faites pas des crumbles avec des
fruits tropicaux de de de chez vous le
crumble au pom crumble P B c'est comme
ça merci priscat d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans politique à table mmeci
au restaurant Les masque à reigne qui
nous ont fourni ce très bon bol rassé et
merci à chez Françoise on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP